and we're joined now by someone who
knows
iraqi kurdistan really well because he's
the head of the german liaison office
for industry and commerce in irbil which
is in northern iraq volkaviltner it's
good to have you here with us and i just
learned that you are here sort of in a
way unvoluntarily you actually came back
to germany on holiday
and now it's tricky for you very
difficult for you to get back to herbal
where you head this german liaison
office
how does that make you feel in this
situation to be stuck here in germany
i feel unhappy about the situation
because i have
employees in abeer which are doing a
daily job and have to do now what i'm
supposed to do in the in
kurdish down in ibia but today with the
media's we can skype we can use the
telephones and as i said it's very
qualified staff it works okay for the
time being on the other side i have so
much to do here in germany because of
inquiries from companies what is
happening when can we travel when is
when are the airlines starting again and
so on that keeps me very busy over here
and i'm also thinking about the time
after the
present problems you know to continue
and fast continue fast and this makes me
quite happy to be also here at the time
yeah well when one watches the news
these days i mean there's nothing but
bad news coming out from that region so
how do you liaise with a country with a
region that's been engulfed in war and
terror for the most part of the past two
decades really
i was quite lucky because i'm living or
i'm living in an area in the uh
autonomic uh
district of uh
of course kurdistan yeah and uh
we hadn't haven't had any problems for
the last few four years i was free i
could do everything we could travel
without security and it was it was a
peaceful country not in comparison to
baccarat where you always said
explosions terroristic things we never
experienced this and in our area as i
said we could travel from doha
suleimania to airbeal without any
security measures what more can you tell
us about the economic situation there
at the moment the economic situation is
very calm because of the situation but
we know from the past we have done a lot
of work for this country a lot of german
companies are interested to start
business starting even operating
investing but we have to wait until
everything is becoming calm in kurdistan
you have the problem that you have to
if you want to do business you have to
do the planning you have to it is very
difficult now isn't it and especially
now yeah but you get but i mean the
situation will become better and you
have to do the planning now and you
cannot start planning when everything is
calm again so when you when you think
that the situation is getting better i
mean you're very optimistic there people
come to you and want to hear your advice
both from the kurdish on also the german
side what do you tell them the companies
there should they stay put wait and see
or better leave and
the companies which are there at the
moment okay they're operating on the
lower level for companies which wanted
to start business in goldstone i would
say we should see and everything is
stabilized and as you said who knows
what is happening we have a lot of talks
now in the european union what is to do
who is going to help and if this is
sorted out and the
situation is stable and controllable
then definitely the company should come
fast because as you mentioned before
there's a lot of potential a lot of
money in this country and it is to be
spent okay
thank you so much for taking the time to
speak to us today thank you for having
me